the third episode of game of thrones'
eighth season saw arya stark go from a
woman to a warrior entitled the long
night the latest chapter in game of
thrones' final season centered on the
battle between the night king and his
army of dead and the Libyan citizens of
Westeros holding strong and Winterfell
the episode also featured more
incredible moments than we can count on
one hand
lots of spoilers beyond this point
obviously the red priestess Melisandre
made a surprise return uniting fire with
ice by calling on the Lord of Light to
set the Dothraki out riders weapons on
fire Daenerys Targaryen and Jon Snow
wrote atop their respective dragons and
attempted to burn out the enemy with
flames from above several characters
like little Lyanna Mormont and Jorah
Mormont sacrificed themselves battling
the whites Theon Greyjoy died defending
brand Stark and the dead in the crypts
of Winterfell rose and began a
terrifying attack on innocent women
children and elderly citizens as intense
as these events surrounding the Battle
of Winterfell were they felt like small
fish compared to what Arya Stark did at
the end of the episode the youngest
Starks sister made the long night that
much more memorable by ending the very
event for which the entire episode was
named in a moment few saw coming
Arya jumped at the night King and
stabbed him driving her Valyrian steel
dagger through an exposed section of his
armor the second the blade made contact
with the frosty villains abdomen the
night Kings shattered to smithereens as
did his army of White Walkers and
White's
arias heroic surprise stunt dropped
viewers jaws and elicited screams of
delight from Game of Thrones fans as the
episode aired live on HBO viewers lit up
social media with real-time reactions to
Arya slaying the night king one fan
tweeted my head hurts from screaming
since the episode started but man this
moment was just amazing Arya Stark well
done Queen Arya killing the night king
is probably one of the most iconic
moments in this show a truly amazing
scene Game of Thrones fan Cameron Stokes
could barely contain his emotions over
Arya stabbing the night king and
defeating the North's greatest threat
Stokes posted to Twitter tonight was
simply the most incredible 125 minutes
in TV history Arya is my favorite TV
character of all time that is
all evidence suggests that aria is true
destiny was to slaughter the night king
and his army and this seemed to be
confirmed during a chat she had with
Melisandre before setting out to save
the day or night as it happens Aria
finds herself face to face with the red
woman who brings up the notion of
purpose in regard to beric Dondarrion
the man who sacrificed himself
protecting Aria from whites in the
library of Winterfell
Melisandre reminds Aria of Barrett's
history of dying multiple times only to
be brought back to life by the Lord of
Light suggesting that he had been kept
alive so he could save Aria during the
Battle of Winterfell ensuring she would
be alive to defeat the night king during
their conversation Aria corroborates
Melisandre's claim of SU sang when she
remembers that the red woman previously
prophesied that the youngest stark girl
would take the lives of many people this
eerie prophecy happened all the way back
in season 3 when Aria confronted
Melisandre for taking her best friend
Gendry away for blood magic purposes
Melisandre told Aria she saw a darkness
in a young girl before alluding to the
number of people she would go on to kill
brown eyes blue eyes green eyes
eyes you'll shut forever we will meet
again
Melisandre repeats her prophecy during
the third episode of season 8
rewording the phrase about the eyes to
place emphasis on the blue ones that
Arya will shut the scrappy stark girl
seems to take this to mean that
Melisandre has seen into a future in
which she kills the night king who has
blue eyes
Arya's mind is made up already but
Melisandre seals the deal when she asks
Arya the same question her first sword
fighting instructor Syrio Forel used to
what do you say to the god of death
not today arias killing of the night
king could impact another major prophecy
that Melisandre often spoke up Ozora hi
also known as the prince that was
promised who is prophesied to end the
long night and provide Westeros with
everlasting peace Melisandre told
Daenerys during season seven that only
the prince who was promised can bring
the dawn and that she believed Danny had
a role to play in the long night ending
she also shared with the mother of
dragons that Jon Snow would be pivotal
to ringing in a new era but there was no
mention of Arya so does this mean the
azure Ahai prophecy is pointless maybe
but then again maybe not Arya still has
a set of green eyes to shut green eyes
many fans believe belonged to Cersei
Lannister
who's presumably sitting cool as a
cucumber down in King's Landing some are
theorizing that maybe the long night
isn't over just yet and that it will
only come to an end when Arya kills the
real threat to Westeros Cersei and her
big green eyes check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about Game of Thrones are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]